翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Kumika Moore
みなさん こんにちは
突然ですが 私から１つだけ
質問をさせてください
みなさん
おならをした後
どういう反応をしますか？
（笑）
例えば授業中
我慢する人もいるかも知れません
ただ黙って知らないふりをする人も
いるかも知れません
自分が やったのにも関わらず
犯人探しをする人もいるかも知れません
（笑）
愉快に 「おならするぞ ワンツースリー ぷ」
みたいな子もいるかも知れません
しかし 僕はどれもできずにいました
とにかく恥ずかしくて恥ずかしくて
仕方ありませんでした
とくに授業中なんか おなら出たりしたら
顔が赤くなって
汗がだっくだくになっちゃって
隠すこともできないし
我慢することは体に悪いっていうことは
みなさんも知っていると思うからです
突然ですが 私は大学になって
彼女が出来ました
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
しかしながら 彼女の前でも
おならをすることは ためらいました
おならに 気を遣ってたんです
（笑）
おならのせいで 気を遣う関係に
なっていたのかも知れません
（笑）
しかし 僕もそんな関係は嫌だなと
思っていました
これは乗り越えなきゃいけないと
本気で思いました
勇気を持って彼女に相談しました
（笑）
「どうしよう？」と
「２人でいる時どうしよう？」と
30分くらい本気で話し合いました
その時 出たのが
僕が紹介したいアイデアです
みなさんも お家でできると思うんです
面白いおならをした方が
アイスをおごってもらえる
（笑）
実際 私も１個
もう既におごってもらってます
（笑）
確かに私にとって
おならは恥ずかしいことです
もちろん するのも恥ずかったことです
しかし おならをすれば
笑わせることができる とか
おならをすることによって
ご褒美がもらえる
そういう風にとらえると
積極的にできるんですね
（笑）
不思議なもんです
もちろん された方も
少し汚いなとは思うんですけど
やっぱり 笑っちゃうんですよね
みんな笑顔になれるんです
そうなんです
（笑）
恥ずかしいことも やりづらいことも
何かご褒美がもらえたりとか
笑ってもらえたりとか
何か得られるものとか
楽しければ
積極的にできるのかも知れません
今回おならで１つの例を挙げましたが
宿題とかそういうことに対しても
そうかも知れません
仕事とか そうかも知れません
おならはご褒美がもらえるもの
ありがとうございました
（拍手）